all right uh sandra we've put a panel
together general jack keen is with us
along with dan hoffman also joining us
this hour is brett bruin he served 12
years as a u.s diplomat as a former
obama white house director of global
engagement and brett why don't we start
with you since you're you're new to the
program this afternoon we heard what
putin had to say a lot of it was
lamenting the fall of the soviet union
that they gave away too much that
ukraine is a false entity that was
created by the former communists there
are a lot of complaints about ukraine
and its treatment toward russia ever
since uh yanukovych left in 2014 under
pressure i mean putin even going so far
is to say that russia will do everything
it can to punish those involved in the
fire in odessa in 2014 and that's when
pro-ukrainian protesters attacked a
building
in which there were pro-russian
ukrainians
burned the building and killed 30 people
inside i mean how do you punish people
responsible for a fire in odessa unless
you're planning on being in the entire
country
yeah it is really worrying what we heard
from vladimir putin this afternoon i
think in a lot of ways he's doubling
down on his threats and and clearly
trying to uh read off a laundry list of
grievances and complaints what i think
is the key question looming over
washington right now is how is president
biden going to respond and up until now
what the administration has said is
we'll slap on some more economic
sanctions but quite frankly after what
we heard from vladimir putin this
afternoon that is not enough he has
clearly not been deterred by what we've
already done and there are some decently
strong economic sanctions in place
already after his invasion of crimea and
luhansk and donetsk in 2014 so the
administration is going to have to put
more on the table they're going to have
to stiffen the spines of our european
allies because this simply cannot stand
john
uh very interesting dan we caught up
with you as we are beginning the show
one o'clock eastern time you've been
able to address a lot of what we've
learned since then especially from the
words of vladimir putin your thoughts
so what i'm waiting for now is the
response from ukraine they're the one
whose country is being dismembered you
know it started back in 2014 when when
putin annexed crimea and launched the
war in donbass and now vladimir putin is
saying that the don boss should be an
autonomous republic of russia and they
should have their independence
recognized that the question for me is
how does ukraine respond there have been
great divisions between the blind
administration and president zielinski
over the fact that we didn't implement
preemptive sanctions that might have uh
taken a step towards inducing russia to
withdraw some of those troops or perhaps
not to take the step that vladimir putin
took today the question for me is
whether ukraine plans to fight for this
territory and i'm sure that's something
that our team on the ground in la viv
unfortunately not in kiev uh is going to
be looking at with the government of
ukraine uh frankly this is not a time
for our embassy to to have departed uh
keefe and and and moved to la vie they
should be they should have remained in
kiev to do their diplomatic work it's
going to be far more difficult for us
right now to manage our affairs with
ukraine uh being so far to the west and
really out of the loop with all of the
government officials with whom we need
to engage at this very perilous moment
uh general keane let's just bring you in
here and put a couple of run a couple of
things by you
uh putin's saying if ukraine gets
weapons of mass destruction the global
situation will change drastically we
cannot ignore this he says ukraine is
flooded with western weapons in recent
months also saying nuclear weapons
amount to preparation for attack on
russia
uh he wants to keep ukraine from
becoming a threat to russia vis-a-vis
nato
read the tea leaves for us general where
do you think this is headed
well i think it's clear i mean
i read through uh
you know some of the analysis and the
snippets that came out of the speech on
reuters and
and it's clearly he's building a case
not to
just occupy the donbass region or even
build a land bridge uh to the east to
crimea
he's building a case to occupy ukraine i
mean that that's what that whole speech
was about
uh certainly not just a limited military
attack uh to
secure much of the territory already
owns and expanded
um and and i think that
was clearly identified by the united
states intelligence services and i agree
with the biden administration in
releasing that information to take away
putin's element of surprise and also to
take away any sense of legitimacy here
by us the united states conducting her
own information campaign
against him and i think we correctly
identified that his
strategic attempt here
is to take control of ukraine and and i
think that speech is really all about
that i mean you it's dripping with
uh the emotion that he feels
uh personally about ukraine
and that is what sandra so correctly
identified in the july 12 000 word a
memo much of it uh penned by himself
according to uh sources in his own
language
and and and secondly while
ukraine has ideological uh overtones to
it it's a democracy and he doesn't want
that certainly and he doesn't want that
kind of impact on his own people
it also has geopolitical issues because
he wants ukraine to look to russia and
not to the west but really when it gets
down to what he is talking about here
is that ukraine never should have been
separated from the soviet union it is a
part of russia and i'm taking back the
land that is rightfully ours
that is what this is about i believe it
will be a phased operation
we'll we'll see if that unfolds it'll
start
in a very
minimal limited way but it will likely
expand over a series of days and i
and i agree with you john i mean we're
waiting to see
uh what the biden administration is
going to do now
um they have forecasted this correctly
and they deserve credit for that but now
it's up to them what are they going to
do about it we already know
for a fact that they've squandered many
of the opportunities that were afforded
to them because this began in march so
our viewers recall with the 70 90 000
occupation last march of 2021
when they encroached on ukraine's border
and we did nothing
and this has been going on all that time
and i thought it was a test then 90 days
into the biden administration they were
preoccupied with a domestic program and
also with afghanistan decision to pull
out of afghanistan made in april
after that fiasco and i think putin
looked at that as we've said so many
times as fundamental weakness on the
part of the united states and nato he
came back
and doubled those forces
in the fall leading up to where we are
right now at the end of february hey
sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else